[Musique]
josé tout je me présente gabriel florian
je suis bénévole dans le comité des
chômeurs du port je ciel à la commission
des affaires sociales du ccas aussi
[Musique]
je commençais à me les professeurs des
écoles je suis en retraite et donc
ensuite j'ai voulu m'investir dans une
cause utile pour s'occuper
sans abri des gens les plus démunis et
cela dure depuis 18 ans on a peu près
une quinzaine une vingtaine
des jouets
ça se passe entre 8 heures et 9 heures
et après on veille à leur page le repas
est offert par la mairie
il reste à peu près 20 minutes et
affriolantes va les faire rentrer par où
je participe aussi à la préparation à la
distribution de colis
alors nous recevons les vives avec les
trônes surface et aussi nous recevons
aussi pas mal de choses de la banque
alimentaire des mascareignes disons
parce que tous les jours on reçoit des
fruits ceux sur les aventures voilà
alors je participe activement on ne veut
pas de melun qui a lieu en décembre
et donc c'est un moment de partage et de
convivialité
alors je suis dévoué donc j'aime rendre
service aux gens autour de moi il y
apporter un peu de réconfort
peu d'entre elles ben parce que je
trouve tellement de misère et toulouse
moi je ne fais pas grand chose mais
j'essaie d'apporter de mémoire et
conférences personnellement pour moi
chaque personne a sa place dans la
société
j'aimerais bien que d'autres personnes
rejoignent l'association et on aimerait
bien aussi avoir un travailleur social
qui ferait le suivi des sans abri tout
groupe humain prend sa richesse dans la
communication l'entr'aide et la
solidarité visant à un but commun
l'épanouissement de chacun dans le
respect des différences
françoise dolto voilà c'est tout